Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Le «piscidétritivore»,
est-ce que ça vous évoque quelque chose ?
Le piscidétritivore est
une nouvelle espèce animale.
Il s'agit d'un poisson.
Un poisson extraordinaire inventé
par Lulu, le héros de mon premier roman.
Ce poisson se nourrit exclusivement
de déchets et dépollue ainsi les océans.
Et vous savez ce que j’aimerais ?
Qu’un scientifique s’en empare.
Et si l’imagination prenait vie ?
Si elle prenait corps, devenait réalité ?
Parce que jusqu’à présent,
ce sont surtout les romans qui
ont été au service de la science,
qui s’en sont inspirés.
La littérature a été
un outil de vulgarisation.
Elle a même pu servir d’exutoire
lorsque la science avait encore besoin
de temps pour affiner une théorie
ou pour préparer l’esprit du lecteur
à représenter le futur.
Du laser à l’hélicoptère, de la fusée
au robot en passant par les sous-marins,
l’art à chercher à décrire les avancées
de la révolution industrielle.
De Montaigne à Cyrano, de La Fontaine
à Diderot, en passant par Orwell,
ou encore Mary Shelley,
tous ces visionnaires ne sont pas
apparus de nulle part.
Ils ont été inspirés
par les débats, les polémiques,
qui animaient la communauté scientifique
de leur temps
et ils ont su synthétiser
ce potentiel en une fiction
qui, quelques années, quelques
décennies plus tard, s’est réalisée.
Il faut savoir que même
Jules Verne, même lui,
ses fameux voyages extraordinaires
n’étaient en fait qu’une commande
proposée par son éditeur.
Hetzel, c’est le nom de cet éditeur,
lui suggère de résumer les connaissances
scientifiques de son époque.
Alors, son ambition est plutôt noble,
puisqu’il s’agit de permettre à tous
l’accès au savoir.
Verne devient donc
le premier grand écrivain populaire
à introduire la science et la technique
dans ses récits.
Alors, bien sûr, il passe de longs moments
à se documenter pour son roman
« De la Terre à la Lune », par exemple.
Il va même jusqu’à suivre des cours
d’astronomie avec Arago,
le grand spécialiste de l’époque,
le Thomas Pesquet de l’époque.
Jules Verne développe donc
une formidable faculté,
celle d’envisager les innovations à venir,
celle de prophétiser
les innovations à venir,
à partir des données
puisées dans son époque.
Mais bon, c’est toujours
le même mouvement :
celui de la littérature
au service de la science.
Peut-être faudrait-il inverser
le regard, non ?
Et si nous revenions au point de départ,
aux origines, à savoir l’école ?
Parce que c’est là, n’est-ce pas,
que s’opère cette première ségrégation
entre filière littéraire
et filière scientifique ?
Aujourd'hui encore, les cursus
sont bien trop étanches.
D’un côté les troubadours,
les doux rêveurs,
de l’autre, les sérieux, les cartésiens
pour ne pas dire d’un côté les
quelconques et de l’autre les élites.
Et bien sûr, je n’irais surtout pas
jusqu’à insinuer d’un côté les filles
et de l’autre les garçons.
Parce que,
on a tous eu cette question à un moment
ou à un autre de notre scolarité :
«Mais es-tu plutôt littéraire
ou plutôt scientifique ?»
Et personnellement, elle m’a toujours
exaspérée, cette question.
Je n’ai jamais compris qu’il y ait
telle une évidence ou une fatalité
à n’être que l’un ou l’autre.
Pourquoi cette injonction restrictive
à prendre parti ?
Alors, autant être claire tout de suite,
en l’état actuel de la recherche,
rien ne permet d’affirmer
qu’il y a des cerveaux plus littéraires
et plus matheux que d’autres,
ni chez les filles, ni chez les garçons.
L'imagerie a montré qu'il n'y a pas
de prédisposition naturelle.
Il s'agit du résultat d'un cheminement,
d'un parcours fait de tâtonnements,
d'erreurs, de réussites.
Et on a évidemment plus d’appétence,
plus d’attirance,
pour ce qui nous procure
de la satisfaction et du plaisir.
Ce choix, ce dilemme, j’ai eu à le faire
et au grand désespoir de certains,
j’ai opté pour les lettres.
Et pourtant on a tort de mettre
dos à dos ces domaines.
Les passerelles existent,
la synergie est là.
La porosité du langage l'atteste.
En maths, on émet des hypothèses,
on raisonne avec des lettres.
On peut même raisonner par l'absurde.
Les nombres sont parfois irrationnels.
On parle d’inconnue, d’infini,
d’hyperbole, de coordonnées.
Et pour manier le tout,
il faut une certaine forme d’intuition.
D’ailleurs, vous savez, en sciences,
même les électrons rêvent d’être libres.
Et si l’on y réfléchit bien, une telle
opposition entre filières scientifique
et littéraire est relativement moderne.
Très longtemps dans l’histoire, la science
et la littérature ont fait bon ménage.
On peut remonter loin, très loin,
bien avant J.C.
Dans l’Antiquité déjà,
avec la fameuse SPA.
Je ne vous parle pas d’animaux,
mais bien de philosophes.
S. P. A.
Je ne sais pas si vous l’avez :
Socrate, Platon, Aristote.
Platon qui affirmait d’ailleurs
que le philosophe était un roi
seul capable de gouverner.
On peut également penser
à Thalès et Pythagore
qui n’ont pas rédigé que des théorèmes.
Ils ont aussi composé de la poésie,
de la philosophie.
On pense également à Averroès,
médecin et philosophe.
On pense évidemment au couteau suisse
de la Renaissance italienne,
ingénieur, anatomiste, peintre,
Léonard de Vinci, bien sûr.
Et on peut remonter comme ça
jusqu’au siècle des Lumières,
avec quasiment tous les grands
savants de l’époque :
Pascal, Diderot, Descartes, Spinoza.
La liste est longue, et inutile de vous
faire remarquer qu’il n’y a pas de femme.
Donc finalement, jusqu’au 19e siècle,
régnait un savoir sans compartiment,
sans frontière.
Au contraire,
les différents domaines de la connaissance
se nourrissaient les uns des autres.
La transdisciplinarité était une évidence.
Il serait peut-être temps
de revenir à ces temps-là, non ?
d’abolir les bornes de ces stéréotypes.
Parce que, comment se passer
d’autant de talents ?
La complémentarité, la mixité,
le métissage sont un atout.
Et si nous appartenions
à une culture unifiée ?
Et si nous cessions d’opposer
le réalisme et l’imaginaire ?
Les chiffres et les lettres main dans
la main pour inventer demain.
Vous allez me dire que
ce n’est pas si simple.
Et pourtant, le ministère
des Armées l’a bien compris.
Et quoi de plus cartésien
que le ministère des Armées ?
Ils ont récemment embauché
des auteurs, dix auteurs,
habilités Secret Défense,
nom de code : la Red Team.
Leur objectif : envisager
les horizons futurs à 2030, 2060.
Une rencontre inédite
des sciences et des arts,
puisqu’ils ont à leur service -
je dis bien : à leur service -
une Blue Team, des chercheurs,
des experts, en soutien aux créatifs.
Emmanuel Chiva, directeur du département
de l’innovation et de la défense
à l’origine du projet, l’affirme :
«Nous sommes prisonniers
de notre mental quotidien.
Nous devons penser en dehors du cadre.»
Cette Red Team envisage
différents scénarios
sur les contraintes et les menaces
de notre société de demain.
Sur des sujets comme le transhumanisme,
l’intelligence artificielle
ou encore les conséquences
du dérèglement climatique.
Je suppose que vous aimeriez
des exemples un petit peu plus concrets.
C'est secret défense.
Malgré tout, je vous en livre deux,
mais ça reste entre nous.
Premier scénario : ils ont supposé
qu’avec la montée des eaux,
nous pourrions être amenés à vivre en mer.
Aussi, ils ont travaillé avec
des spécialistes de la pisciculture
pour savoir comment faire pour nourrir une
population de plus de 100 000 habitants
vivant uniquement sur l'eau.
Deuxième scénario :
ils ont imaginé que nous pourrions
être conduits à vivre dans l’espace.
Pour cela, ils ont imaginé
un ascenseur spatial.
Aussi, ils ont travaillé avec un expert
dans les matériaux de la haute atmosphère
pour savoir comment réaliser
des câbles de carbone
de plus de 36 000 kilomètres de long.
Ça vous semble un peu dingue ?
C'est aussi ce qu'on disait à l'époque
du tunnel sous la Manche
ou du canal du Panama.
Il nous faut ainsi un décadrage,
un pas de côté.
Thinking out of the box.
Vous connaissez peut-être ce problème
des neuf points qu’il faut relier
en seulement quatre lignes.
Eh bien, cette énigme ne peut être
résolue qu'en sortant du cadre.
Seule la fiction répond à ce besoin.
Elle élargit le monde,
elle élargit les horizons,
elle augmente la réalité.
Pour preuve, aujourd’hui, lorsqu’on évoque
l’histoire d’une entreprise,
se réfère-t-on uniquement
à son chiffre d’affaires ?
Ça ne suffit pas, ça ne suffit plus.
On le fait à travers
le fameux storytelling.
Preuve que nous avons besoin de récits.
Nous avons besoin de sens, d'émotion,
d'apporter de la chair à nos vies.
Parce que le monde de demain
est en pleine mutation.
Parce qu'il est à renouveler,
à réenchanter.
Il doit aussi passer par
une modification de notre vision
sur la hiérarchisation des savoirs.
Et qui mieux que les littéraires
pour réinventer demain ?
Pas un demain qui,
à travers un méta écran,
reproduirait notre monde réel à
l’identique en asséchant nos imaginaires.
Non, au contraire.
Un demain qui, ici,
sur cette planète, dirait :
« Ensemble, tout est possible. »
Emmanuel Chiva, à l’origine du projet
de la Red Team, l’affirmait :
«Nous sommes saturés
de science et de technologie.
Nous sommes confrontés
au mur de l’imaginaire.»
Eh bien, faisons tomber ce mur.
Alors, s’il vous plaît, s’il vous plaît,
ne rangez pas votre imagination
au temps qui s’englue dans les boîtes
poussiéreuses de votre enfance.
Ayez l'audace d'arracher
vos rêves au temps.
Cultivez le merveilleux, le féerique,
de ces premières années où un seul cerveau
servait à imaginer des mondes.
Peut-être connaissez-vous
cette phrase de René Char :
«Impose ta chance, serre ton bonheur,
à te regarder, ils s’habitueront. »
Eh bien, je vous le dis :
Impose ta création,
Cultive ton imaginaire,
Et ensemble, ensemble,
soyons des littérafiques.
Soyons des scientiraires.
(Applaudissements)